[Music]
there is a battle for control in Iran
between far-right hardliners and
relative moderates hardliners generally
support aggressive foreign policy and
reject even limited political and
economic freedoms moderates
contrastingly support the Iran nuclear
deal and some economic reform like more
trade with Europe but in Iran's 2020
parliamentary elections the regime
disqualified most moderate candidates
and hardliners won turnout hit historic
lows Iranians are angry with the unfair
elections in 2019 moderates headed
Iran's three government branches
hardliners will control - in 2020 if a
far-right candidate becomes president in
2021 which is likely they will head all
three branches growing hardliner control
will facilitate more aggressive and
authoritarian behavior the Islamic
Revolutionary Guards Corps would further
destabilize the region and oppressor ons
populace likely exacerbating domestic
anger with the regime Iran's political
landscape is changing profoundly and
there's trouble ahead for Iran's people
the Middle East and yes most probably
the United States
do you think a hardliner will win Iran's
presidential election in 2021 let us
know in our poll also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI